ammonia is an example of a weak base and
hydrochloric acid is an example of a
strong acid ammonia reacts with
hydrochloric acid to form an aqueous
solution of ammonium chloride
and because this is an acid-based
neutralization reaction there's only a
single arrow going to the right
indicating the reaction goes to
completion
next let's write the overall or complete
ionic equation let's start with ammonia
ammonia is a weak base and weak base is
only partly ionized in aqueous solution
therefore since weak base is only partly
ionized we're not going to show this as
an ion we're simply going to write nh3
in our equation however for hydrochloric
acid hydrochloric acid is a strong acid
and strong acids ionize 100 percent
therefore an aqueous solution we need to
show this as the ions so h plus
and cl minus
ammonium chloride is a soluble salt
therefore in aqueous solution we show it
as the ions so ammonium chloride
consists of the ammonium ion nh4 plus
and the chloride anion cl minus
to save some time i've drawn in the
aqueous subscripts and also put in the
reaction arrow and a plus sign so this
represents the overall or the complete
ionic equation
and we can use the complete ionic
equation to find the net ionic equation
for this weak base strong acid reaction
to do that we first need to identify
these spectator ions and remember these
are the ions that do not take part in
the chemical reaction since there's a
chloride anion on the left side and on
the right side the chloride anion is the
spectator ion for this reaction
and once we take out our spectator ion
we're left with our net ionic equation
which is aqueous ammonia plus h plus
yields nh4 plus
so this is one way to write our net
ionic equation however remember that h
plus and h3o plus are used
interchangeably in chemistry therefore
another way to write the net ionic
equation is to show aqueous ammonia plus
the hydronium ion h3o plus yields the
ammonium ion nh4 plus plus water
now that we have our net ionic equation
we're going to consider three different
situations in the first situation we
have equal moles of our weak base and
strong acid
looking at our net ionic equation the
mole ratio of ammonia to hydronium ion
is one to one therefore if we have equal
moles of our weak base and strong acid
the weak base and strong acid will
completely neutralize each other and
produce the ammonium ion nh4 plus
so if our goal is to figure out the ph
of the resulting solution we don't need
to consider the weak base or this strong
acid we need to think about the ammonium
cation in aqueous solution
and in solution the ammonium cation acts
as a weak acid and donates a proton to
water to form the hydronium ion h3o plus
and aqueous ammonia the ammonium cation
nh4 plus is a weak acid therefore the ka
value is less than one and since ka is
less than one at equilibrium there are
mostly reactants and not very many
products however the concentration of
hydronium ions in solution is increased
and therefore the resulting solution
will be acidic
so the resulting solution will be
slightly acidic and at 25 degrees
celsius the ph of the solution will be
less than seven if we wanted to
calculate the actual ph we would treat
this like a weak acid equilibrium
problem also it's important to emphasize
that the hydronium ions that gave the
resulting solution a ph less than seven
came from the reaction of the ammonium
cation with water the hydronium ions did
not come from the strong acid all of
those hydronium ions were used up in the
acid-base neutralization reaction
for the second situation we have more of
the weak base than the strong acid
therefore we have the weak base in
excess
and because the mole ratio of the weak
base the strong acid is one to one if we
have more of the weak base than the
strong acid all of the strong acid will
be used up
so when the reaction goes to completion
we'll have ammonium cations in solution
and we'll also have some leftover
ammonia
so after the neutralization reaction is
complete and all the h3o plus is used up
we'll have some leftover ammonia that
ammonia will react with water to form
hydroxide anions and nh4 plus
because the concentration of hydroxide
ions in solution has increased at 25
degrees celsius
the resulting solution will be basic and
the ph will be greater than seven
if we wanted to calculate the actual ph
we would treat this like a weak base
equilibria problem however we have two
sources for the ammonium cation one
source is from ammonia reacting with
water to form nh4 plus and the other
source came from the neutralization
reaction so actually this would be a
common ion effect problem
the other way to calculate the ph of
this solution is to realize that
ammonium nh4 plus is a weak acid and
ammonia nh3 is its conjugate base
therefore if we have similar amounts of
a weak acid and its conjugate base we
have a buffer solution and we could
calculate the ph using the
henderson-hasselbach equation
for our third situation let's say we
have the strong acid in excess
since the mole ratio of weak base to
strong acid is 1 to one if we have more
of the strong acid than the weak base
all of the weak base will be used up and
we'll have some strong acid in excess
therefore there'll be a concentration of
hydronium ions in solution which would
make the resulting solution acidic so at
25 degrees celsius the ph would be less
than 7.
we could calculate the actual ph of the
resulting solution by doing a strong
acid ph calculation problem
and while it's true that the ammonium
cation can function as a weak acid and
also increase the concentration of
hydronium ions it's such a small
increase compared to the hydronium ions
we have in solution from our strong acid
that we don't need to worry about the
contribution of the ammonium cations we
can just treat this like a strong acid
ph calculation problem